all right everybody Pixar's Incredibles
- as a new trailer the sequel appears to
follow up the events from the first 2004
movie exploring a new career opportunity
for Elastigirl and mr. Incredibles
trials raising baby Jack Jack as his
unhealthy powers terrorized the
household so let's break down this
trailer and point out all the big
details that you might have missed what
do you say guys yes please alright first
off this movie looks like it'll pick up
immediately where the first movie left
off in its final scene the family
responding to an attack by the
Underminer
by the way that's Pixar voiceover actor
regular John Ratzenberger doing the
voice there he does a cameo in every
movie and a detail that I actually find
interesting about this is the time
period The Incredibles takes place in a
alternate time period check out the cars
I always saw The Incredibles as set in a
kind of world that's removed from time
like kind of a classic Neil Futurist
aesthetic kind of like this the sixties
view of the future in the Jetsons kind
of thing now some people pointed out
that in the first movie Bob a mr.
incredible reads a newspaper that's
dated May 16 1962
so that should explain to you why
everything is 60th 60-ish design wise
it's just it's they're consistent with
it because some people say well if you
actually do the timeline it's like it's
set in the 70s but it's all they're just
going for the 60s aesthetic which i
think is really fun let's move on to
another detail that I noticed in this
trailer the new character voiced by Bob
Odenkirk his name is Winston
Dever he's a corporate hotshot clearly
modeled on own Kirk's character Saul
Goodman from better Breaking Bad in
better call Saul now this characters
wife is being played by Catherine Keener
or voiced by Catherine Keener her name
is Evelyn Dever which is kind of a fun
Tom Riddle a play on words revealing
probably what her true nature is Evelyn
Dever evil endeavor we'll see what comes
from that there's also this bit with Bob
trying to help - with this new math
homework
new math was actually the name given to
a progressive approach to math education
in the 50s and that was scrapped and I'm
sure if you're a parent today you can
probably relate to the new unfamiliar
strategies that schools are trying to
use to teach kids math it's like how was
math changed math is math and then
lastly check out the logo on elastic
girl's costume they restored a last
girl's original logo which was a sleek
letter II combined with a letter G which
is part of original costume before she
mr. and mr. incredible got married in
that opening prologue scene in the first
Incredibles movie it's interesting now
that they choose to do away with her
lowercase I from The Incredibles family
logo on Edna Motz costumes so do you
guys think this mean maybe Helen is
trying to reclaim her into that
individuality after years of playing
homemaker what do you guys think about
that and what do you guys think about
this trailer in general well I actually
reached The Incredibles this week
because I was just like I knew this was
gonna come out and I was like I've
happened I watched it one time as a
child in the theater and I don't really
remember a lot of it so rewatching it
was very fun because it just felt like
watching a brand new Pixar movie it's
amazing by the way if you guys haven't
watched in awhile you should definitely
check it out but also picking up right
after is a really interesting thing
because during that movie the dad is
there he's being very selfish like he's
choosing to like go behind his wife and
his family's back so that he can like
relive the glory days and also there's a
fun there's a fun bit in when they're
talking about no capes and they actually
drop one of the dates that in 58 one of
the that's when that girl got stuck to
the airplane engine yeah but no I'm very
excited I like that she now gets the
chance it's basically showing that he
learned his lesson and is allowing light
not allowing she's like he's just trying
to be a better parent and like he's
gonna take over like household duties
while she gets also with her chance to
be a superhero once again so I'm I'm
down for that yeah it's uh it's
interesting how they're choosing to do
this sequel and that they're choosing to
do it after what is it
14 years later the listen Bri watches
trailer and listen to the audio from
Dash and from violet they had to get new
voice actors to play those parts because
they had kids playing those parts in
2002 or 2003 when they initially the
movie came out 2004 but those those were
kids they're adults now they got kids
who sound exactly like - and viola it's
amazing man he's a man of a thousand
voices I'm really curious to see what
kind of nods are gonna be especially
since they share a universe yeah yeah
and the Pixar extended universe is
extremely dense and everything's making
reference to each other I know we did a
video that went to like the logic of the
cars universe you did and then you guys
actually made a video about explaining
the possibility of how all these Pixar
movies could be connected so check out
the video we've also done videos on
other Pixar properties including a full
breakdown with Coco which is one of my
favorite movies from last year but yeah
let us know what you think about this
trailer what are you most excited about
about about Incredibles 2 and yeah make
sure to subscribe to new rock stars for
deep dives into Pixar and all the other
movies that you love thank you guys
you